[Música]
en primera plana
carlos
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france-inter internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la llamada ola invisible de la pandemia
en las consecuencias psicológicas que
deja la comida a su paso para ello me
acompañan en este estudio mario genia
uriburu psicóloga especialista en psico
traumas y terapias de orientación
psicoanalítica bienvenida a mario genial
ariana cancio es psicóloga clínica
bienvenida muchas gracias y mi compañero
miguel martínez corresponsal de tv
azteca que en francia bienvenido miguel'
muchas gracias carlos las consecuencias
psicológicas de la pandemia hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
la pandemia ha tenido y sigue teniendo
un gran impacto en la vida de las
personas durante este tiempo se ha
hablado mucho de sus consecuencias
sanitarias y económicas pero qué ocurre
con las consecuencias psicosociales y
hay varios estudios que muestran como el
estrés y la preocupación influyeron en
el comportamiento durante estos durante
los primeros y desconcertantes meses de
pandemia pero ya más a largo plazo
algunos comienzan a hablar de la ola
invisible de la pandemia de las
consecuencias que muchas de nuestras
mentes deja lakovic repasemos algunas
portadas antes de abordar el tema diario
l'humanité el 40 por ciento de los
jóvenes trabajadores se encuentra en
depresión por la comida revista muy
interesante dedica uno de sus números al
impacto psicológico de la comida cómo
superar la ansiedad depresión y otras
secuelas de la pandemia en los últimos
tiempos hemos podido encontrar varios
artículos como este en publicaciones
especializadas
de lara como la este de la revista
'nature sobre cómo los científicos están
usando métodos de datanálisis para
establecer esa relación entre estrés
mental y medidas para luchar contra la
pandemia en buena mar eugenia somos
conscientes de esta ley visible incluso
no sé si que les parece este término de
ola invisible
la ola efectivamente existe
invisible sí y no porque depende de las
personas pero por supuesto que estamos
frente a una crisis sanitaria que tiene
también una crisis posible económica y
una crisis psicológica
individual in the niebla
llegamos invisible porque se palpa menos
a lo mejor visualmente no puedo no poder
no es lo mismo que la sanitaria o que la
económica y por eso a lo mejor hay que
hay que darle hay que darle ese adjetivo
no sé si está de acuerdo con este
término de lo invisible ariadna si
bien frente al término invisible parece
que aquí no porque se siente no está
presente tal vez justamente la pandemia
lo que permite es visibilizar más está
esta situación de crisis que la gente se
pregunte más estamos frente a una
revuelta vincularnos donde se repiensa
sobre los vínculos que se tienen con uno
mismo con los otros
con la familia con el trabajo y hay un
movimiento
un evento disruptivo que produce
incertidumbre que genera angustia
frente a lo que no se sabe hay angustia
y también decir que frente a la
situación por la que vivimos que
seguimos viendo todavía en este casi dos
años es un mundo que hay una situación
psicológica económica y política que
vamos a vivir y que vamos a descubrir
también porque apenas ahora y aquí se
empieza a hablar de estos temas vamos a
descubrir el verdadero impacto que tuvo
todas las medidas restrictivas en la
sociedad en europa que hay que hubo
confinamientos y toques de queda y esto
yo creo que apenas apenas va a empezar a
salir a emerger y vamos a ver realmente
el impacto que tuvo si es que a lo mejor
es esta la cuestión a mejor no somos
conscientes todavía no tenemos la
suficiente atalaya del tiempo para ver
de qué tamaño es estable invisible como
nos ha afectado mentalmente la pandemia
lo mejor todavía es pronto no mario
genial y yo creo que estamos en un
segundo tiempo por supuesto el
confinamiento fue un evento traumático
para todo el mundo sólo qué traumático
entre millas para algunos más y otros
para otros menos pero por supuesto
dependiendo de qué tipo de persona
es decir cuál era el perfil de cada
persona estando en primera
en el frente de la pandemia haciendo los
médicos el personal de salud por ejemplo
los periodistas y el resto de los seres
humanos que hemos estado encerrados en
nuestras casas o que no podíamos
trabajar y que estábamos
efectivamente confinados el tiempo del
confinamiento fue un tiempo muy
particular potencialmente traumático
pero efectivamente muy angustiante
porque nos presentamos ante lo impensado
lo imposible de pensar que de repente se
frene el mundo
efectivamente es un tiempo muy
particular luego hay algunos tiempos del
des confinamiento y los tiempos que han
permitido por seguidos las otras olas y
los otros confinamientos han generado
movimientos diferentes en este momento
estamos aún en este confinamiento
posible quinta ola son momentos post de
post trauma que podríamos decir
donde se resignifican las cosas de otra
manera
las fases de estos tiempos de los que
nos está hablando una encrucijada
que nos pone entre entre adaptarnos a
esta situación o iniciar una nueva vida
para lo que se necesita recursos de
mayor plasticidad una mayor flexibilidad
repensar la situación de lo mismo y
tomar ser agente no de su propio de su
propia realidad como decíamos hay que
tomar decisiones si uno continúa
haciendo lo que hacía antes de la
pandemia se encuentra con una realidad
donde no lo puede salir de su casa no y
me parece que este primer momento de la
pandemia del confinamiento del encierro
donde se toman medidas de distancia
social donde la comunicación con el otro
o el encuentro del con el otro se da de
una manera virtual
y nos hace repensar nos drone desde el
trabajo donde había impensables
justamente desde hacer teletrabajo desde
una consulta psicológica donde
durante largo tiempo se pensó que sí que
tenía que ser en el consultorio en
persona en el cuerpo a cuerpo y nos
encontramos con que esto ya no es más
posible entonces hay una nueva propuesta
y eso es afecta colectivamente porque no
es solamente ciertas personas que
estamos con estas imposibilidades sino
que se encuentra el mundo entero en un
cambio el
énfasis por ejemplo conoces el mundo
estudiantil los universitarios sobre
todo que al inicio cuando empezaron las
medidas restrictivas por lo menos en
europa y una parte del mundo
hay que decirlo hay una generación que
iba a empezar a estudiar que perdieron
lo más importante que es su primer año
de cursos no conocieron absolutamente a
su generación al inicio de sus estudios
todo era por tener por videoconferencia
y del otro lado también los alumnos los
estudiantes que ya estaban finalizando
sus cursos que quedaron totalmente
perdidos porque iban a entrar a un
mercado laboral que que fue inexistente
y que sigue todavía haciendo inexistente
entonces están todavía bajo esa bajo
esas medidas y los estudiantes que
inician o que terminaron su
universidad se encuentran en atrevería a
decir no sistema chrome un poco con una
generación un poco perdida
bajo estas medidas que se dieron esto
que comentas mi compañero miguel es muy
interesante porque imaginamos que hay
colectivos que han sufrido una carga
mental y les pregunta a las psicólogas
mayor durante la pandemia estoy pensando
por ejemplo del personal sanitario pero
también en las mujeres que han tenido
que soportar una mayor carga eso le pasa
que siempre de la vida con las mujeres
pero en tiempos de pandemia todavía más
no marc gené sí efectivamente
las poblaciones
particularmente vulnerables claro y
lamentablemente si las mujeres
encontrándose no solamente con la
dificultad del trabajo de distancia o
con él directamente sin trabajar a
distancia y estar
directamente trabajando con los chicos
ocuparse de la escolaridad
que quien ha tenido más personas a su
cargo es decir las mujeres los
cuidadores de ancianos el personal
sanitario es decir hay gente que tiene
una responsabilidad en tiempos de
pandemia
de varias personas y imaginemos que esa
carga mental tiene que salir en algún
momento efectivamente carga mental de no
contaminar de poder organizarla las
compras la
comida la de pasar el mensaje de educar
de acompañar a la ansiedad que esto
genera a todo el mundo a toda la familia
y por supuesto en el caso de extremo
donde hay además violencia también que
es esta violencia doméstica donde se vio
que el encierro aumentó por supuesto
estos casos
si el agotamiento mental que hoy en día
va desde hace dos años vive el personal
sanitario
los cambios de paradigma la falta de
acompañamiento por ahí a niveles de las
medidas políticas en sanidad el desborde
que hubo y el afrontar nuevas maneras de
hacer frente a esto y sobre todo sino
también como una de las mujeres en el
caso donde han habido violencia
doméstica una mujer que
antes tenía como un momento de
tranquilidad cuando esta persona con la
comparte la habitación no estaba ahora
estar todo el día no son las personas
más vulnerables
y a todo esto la pandemia vuelve a
europa especialmente europa es de nuevo
el epicentro yo creo que claro la
incertidumbre de no ver la luz al final
del túnel es una cosa que puede agobiar
mucho al ser humano hay países de nuevo
que vuelven incluso a confinar lo
estamos viendo en austria países bajos
es verdad que en francia todavía las
restricciones son más ligeras lo acaba
de anunciar esta semana misma semana en
el gobierno de manuel macro pero de
nuevo europa en el punto de mira amiga
sí y también me gustaría acompañar lo
que está diciendo sobre todo la que hay
muchas medidas totalmente
contradictorias entonces por ejemplo con
el regreso con el tema de salud
la atención que está viviendo en el
sector médico y que por ejemplo en
francia que ahora se impuso a partir de
septiembre que el personal médico que no
está vacunado no va a trabajar ni
siquiera no que lo van a correr
simplemente no va a trabajar a eso hay
que agregarle esa carga laboral y
psicológica a los hospitales que se han
se han quedado sin personal porque bueno
si la gente decidiendo vacunarse bueno
vamos a decir en su libertad pero bueno
imponer medidas de ese tipo
aumenta aumenta mucho la carga la carga
psicológica les quiero preguntar a las
psicólogas sobre la duración es posible
determinar de una forma más o menos con
confiada si los efectos serán
transitorios contingentes o si se
configuran secuelas psicológicas
adversas a largo plazo se pueden
establecer los plazos que pueden tener
estos efectos de la pandemia
lo que podemos estar seguros es que hay
que crear una nueva normalidad ya no es
el mundo ya no es como era antes
entonces efectivamente la diferencia
entre las personas que han podido
resignificar
este trauma y volver a encontrar sentido
volver a aproximarse sobre difícil
adaptarse en cierta medida no me gusta
este término pero bueno está bueno las
personas que son menos vulnerables y que
han podido
resignificar el
evento de otra manera
se encontrarán quizás en menos
dificultad si de todas maneras es como
es una normalidad nueva que hay que
crear no sabemos si es la quinta o la la
última sabemos que esto puede durar
cinco
horas más diez años veinte años no
sabemos el mundo cambió y las
consecuencias serán a largo plazo
efectivamente vamos a hacer en este
momento una breve pausa y enseguida
continuamos hablando de esa ola
invisible de las consecuencias
psicológicas de la comida aquí en
primera plana
[Música]
nuestros equipos recogen los testimonios
de los que viven la noticia una mirada
diferente a la actualidad
vídeos que no verá en ningún otro sitio
los observadores en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días
intuitivo rápido y en cuatro lenguas
france24 puntocom liberté égalité actual
y te continuamos en primera plana esta
semana hablando de la llamada ola
invisible de las consecuencias
psicológicas que nos deja la pandemia lo
hacemos con dos psicólogas maría eugenia
uriburu y ariadna cancio y se incorpora
esta mesa ricardo está la corresponsal
del espectador buenos días ricardo i
manilles buena ricardo de nuevo europa
se convierte en estos momentos en el
centro de la pandemia y algunos países
como austria o países bajos vuelven a
fuertes restricciones no sé si podemos
hacer en este punto un breve apoyo
periodístico para explicar hasta qué
punto los anti vacunas están tienen la
responsabilidad de estas nuevas
restricciones en europa
claro el problema es que los anti
vacunas a pesar de no ser numerosos en
digamos europa occidental tienen un peso
político en particular en francia nos
acercamos a la campaña presidencial y yo
pienso que francia va a chrome va a
limitar las restricciones va a tratar de
no ir tan lejos justamente para no
molestar a ese electorado que tiene un
peso entonces hay un peso político de no
molestar estos sectores y creo que eso
está jugando en ciertos países para que
las medidas tarden en ser impuestas
finalmente las medidas tendrán que
tomarse tarde o temprano y yo creo que
austria las tomo temprano y las tomo
radicales y finalmente los otros países
terminarán por hacerlo pero fíjense que
cuando creíamos que no íbamos a volver a
confinamientos a toques de queda y de
repente de nuevo europa en el centro del
huracán y de nuevo ese tipo de medidas
cuando nos creamos que la vacuna nos iba
a proteger de ello claro creo que el
gran problema de comunicación de los de
los gobiernos de europa y el mundo es no
saber decir no sabemos vamos a ver es ir
a afirmar que la vacuna no se iba a
permitir regresar a la vida normal
cuando realmente todavía no sabíamos
cuánto a la inmunidad fue irresponsable
y justamente le da más argumentos de las
personas que están contra la vacunación
o los certificados sanitarios
maría eugenia esta pesadilla que estamos
describiendo sin final es decir volver a
hablar de europa como epicentro volver a
hablar de confinamiento volver cuando
esa situación de incertidumbre sirve no
poder establecer fecha fin a la pandemia
esto me imagino que mentalmente lo más
duro que tenemos que aguantar los
ciudadanos no no no no poder decir esta
es la fecha
efectivamente para el aparato psíquico
funcionamos con fecha es claro la mente
humana y esto está en situación de
incertidumbre sin poder poner un final
debe ser tremendo no
si efectivamente no es fácil no poder
saber exactamente qué lo si lo que uno
proyecta lo que la persona piensa que
puede hacer lo que desea hacer va a ser
posible
afecta por supuesto la organización del
tiempo libre de las vacaciones del
deporte afecta digamos muchos detalles
de la vida cotidiana y la incertidumbre
es si una fuente de digamos de
mucha ansiedad depresión cansancio les
quiero preguntar a todos ariadna ricardo
maría eugenia esta pandemia puede marcar
un antes y un después en la posición que
la salud mental ocupa en la sociedad es
decir hemos de ese estereotipado y la
terapia gracias a la pandemia
vamos a pensar que esto marca adelante
es un después me parece que también es
cultural viniendo de argentina donde la
psicología tiene peso fuerte desde hace
muchísimos años donde el acceso a la
salud mental es gratuito entonces lo que
permite que cualquier persona de
cualquier estrato social pueda tener
acceso a la salud mental me parece que
es necesario implementar políticas de
salud mental en europa y en otros
lugares del mundo donde el acceso sea
posible
y que ese acceso va a permitir que todo
el mundo pueda ir que ya no sea una
cuestión de recursos
porque finalmente cuando empezamos
terapias nos damos cuenta que hace bien
hablar que es necesario ese espacio
en ese sentido precisamente que estaba
comentando y francia- reembolsará creo
que recordar entre 30 y 40 euros por
consultas psicológicas es una respuesta
política adecuada tras las alertas
lanzadas por los profesionales en los
últimos meses por la degradación de la
salud mental este tipo de propuestas es
decir que los gobiernos vayan
acompañando
independientemente del signo ideológico
que puedan tener que vayan acompañando
esto es algo bueno que nos puede dejar
la pandemia podemos pensarlo como un
voto positivo que empieza a moverse algo
no me parece que la manera en la que
está establecido en este momento esta
propuesta
donde la psicología depende de un
discurso en médico hegemónico
pero me parece una puerta de entrada
para empezar la conversación no pero hoy
en día tener que pasar primero por el
médico tratante para que él decida que
se den diez sesiones de psicología luego
encontrar un psicólogo y luego volver al
médico tratante para que decida otra vez
me parece que es con las salas
restricciones no y con las con las
contrariedades que hay a empezar terapia
a hacer todo este movimiento pero sí que
hay que dar un poco más de lugar el
psicólogo ricardo y yo creo que hay un
punto importante que que no hemos
abordado aún y es la ruptura social
entre las personas que están por la
vacuna y los controles y los que están
cocina que yo creo que también incluso a
nivel familiar incluso a nivel de amigos
en una situación no lo ha sufrido lo que
está diciendo ricardo en una situación
en la que quisiéramos renovar después de
los meses de confinamiento y toques de
queda en las salas sociales nos
encontramos con que muchas veces ya va a
haber un conflicto que además es cada
vez más radical porque pues desde los
dos lados hay cada vez menos tolerancia
es el otro los
dicen por culpa los no vacunados las
restricciones los los no vacunados dicen
las nuevas restricciones prueban que la
vacuna no está funcionando entonces ya
estaba en solicitación difícil del lazo
social y eso agravará mero genio como
ven la fractura de la que está hablando
ricardo es que yo creo que todos lo
hemos experimentado quien más quien
menos ha tenido en su entorno una
persona con la que nos ha podido
entender en un debate tan íntimo como
que al final del debate está la
cuestiones o valores como puede ser el
egoísmo
por solidaridad si efectivamente es como
encontrarse de repente con que la
mayoría de las personas juegan el juego
propuesto para poder protegerse para
poder cuidarse porque es también
bastante duro
entender y aceptar que efectivamente hay
que no se puede besar más al otro no se
lo puede tocar hay que ponerse una
máscara y luego pasamos a la vacuna y
así vamos a seguir
seguimos este cambiando y adaptándonos a
la situación es difícil de repente como
sentir que la otra persona la que nos
respeta que no se pone la máscara o que
no se quiere vacunar dice este tablero
no me sirve yo no quiero jugar entonces
es bastante estabilizador para la
persona que dice bueno yo sigo las
reglas se supone que esto me va a
proteger se supone que esto me va a
ayudar y de repente encontrar un
discurso diferente de este de este punto
de vista
y genera conflictos efectivamente pero
creo que no y sobre todo se genera una
grieta a nivel familiar on ahora vienen
las fiestas una piensa ahora con quién
se va a encontrar en la familia y cuál
va a ser el debate no sé me parece que
hay que tomar un poco de responsabilidad
cada uno y de frenar esta pandemia y
esto lo que tenemos entre todos tomando
siguiendo los gestos barreras estamos
apostando a
bienestar general y lo que pasa que es
verdad que ricardo hablaba de esos lazos
de restablecer esos lazos pero claro
esos lazos cuando hay un conflicto en
dos posiciones distintas significa hacer
tabú del tema en esta cena familiar para
poder cenar eso es lo complicado no
se hace tabú para resolver pues creo que
no sé si se puede seguir haciendo está
bien no creo que la gente esté en
realidad con la mentalidad de la gente
en las dos posiciones habla
y bueno efectivamente ahora con las
fiestas de diciembre en todas partes
creo que va con tiene muchos conflictos
y eso agrava pues precisamente todo este
problema de esa ola invisible de
problemas psicológicos de problemas de
relaciones sociales porque incluso gente
que nos es cercana y que puede ser un
apoyo en un momento de incertidumbre
económica social de salud pues no está
ahí porque estamos en desacuerdo sobre
un punto fundamental
en que miente a quien que ha influido la
cantidad de información de noticias
diarias basadas sobre la pandemia e
impactos que hemos recibido a diario a
nuestra salud mental mário genio pone el
tiempo que hemos ocupado cerebralmente
con este yo creo que esto es el tremendo
efectivamente y los impactos a cada paso
a cada minuto
efectivamente había mucha ansiedad al
principio
todo el mundo necesita información
la inestabilidad fue general los
políticos mismos no sabían frente a este
virus desconocido cómo reaccionar qué
medidas tomar cómo que proponer a la
gente
la necesidad de imágenes de información
de cuántos datos fue muy fuerte hubo
muchos abusos porque hubo un montón de
datos y estudios que nos dimos cuenta
que al final el plástico o el metal
aguantaba más aguantaba menos el virus
que teníamos que dejar las bananas o las
naranjas 5 horas en el freezer en fin
cada uno ha ido adaptándose a esta
situación y el hecho de muchas personas
tomar la iniciativa de distanciarse de
leer cada vez menos de estar siguiendo
menos los números esto ha sido esto que
decía la posibilidad de adaptarse la
posibilidad de
encontrar un equilibrio de encontrar un
equilibrio y justamente me parece que la
virtualidad que género sea lo que empuja
ahora es a pensar este espacio ya
cuidarlo no el espacio virtual la
comunicación las noticias a tomar una
distancia y pensarlo como un espacio más
constructivo y no simplemente la
imposibilidad de discutir con el otro
leer noticias y esta sobredosis de
información que puede ser tan dañino
cuando esta información es falsa
recargo que es el uso cuando y cuando la
información es verdadera es realmente un
bombardeo yo recuerdo ante el primer
confinamiento todo el tiempo es
terminando el número de casos en cada
país está
claro esto agrega a la inestabilidad la
imposibilidad de proyectarse y como lo
hemos venido diciendo cada vez que
pensamos que ya que que es pasó a la
pandemia que con la vacuna empieza de
nuevo entonces
sería sano desconectarse pero también es
necesario estar informado lo que está
pasando claro es el lo complicado del
equilibrio me gustaría preguntarles no
sé si alguna de las psicólogas no puede
responder desde un punto de vista
científico cómo se están estudiando las
consecuencias de la pandemia sobre la
salud mental se requieren complejos
diseños de investigación de observación
arianna mario genial
hay muchísimos estudios que se pueden
realizar en el 2020 un boom de estudios
la cuestión como todo estudio o
producción o ciencia en psicología es
que intenta predecir la conducta
pero de pronto puede aparecer otra cosa
nueva una contingencia y cambia todo y
toda esta teoría y predicción se cae
entonces parece que tiene que ver mucho
con la historia personal de cada uno con
lo histórico del contexto del momento y
con los recursos con los que cuenta una
persona para afrontar podemos pensar en
muchísimos efectos o secuelas pero no
las vamos a saber hasta dentro de unos
años cuando podemos corroborar los las
nuevas generaciones lo que no podemos
estar de acuerdo que hemos de ese
estereotipado el hecho de ir a terapia
gracias a la pandemia ricardo no sé si
fue gracias a la pandemia yo creo que ya
había un proceso como de asumir que la
gente necesita pensar en su salud mental
necesita ser escuchada en un marco
profesional y creo que la pandemia pues
efectivamente aceleró un poco en un
momento como que por una vez estamos
todos en el mismo barco todos estamos
angustiados estresados con miedo al
futuro y pues hay que admitir que
necesitábamos ayuda pues me quedo sin
tiempo para más muchísimas gracias por
haberme acompañado en este programa
sobre la ola psicológica de la pandemia
mayo genia uriburu ariadna canción
ricardo abdalá y mi compañero miguel
martínez ya estuvo en la primera parte
pero ahora muchísimas gracias a los
cuatro ya todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana quien en primera plana gracias